- Are you serious?
(playful classical music)
- We are eating food that is
the same color as each other?
- I'm very non-experimental
when it comes to food.
- Is it edible?
- I think you should be
open-minded about trying new things
as long as it's healthy
and won't kill you.
- Yeah, I might die of
food poisoning today.
- Does color make difference in food?
Yes, I think so.
I would not eat a blue pizza.
- This is so fucked up.
It looks like I have a red
pepper and some good old ketchup.
- It kind of reminds me of like
how sriracha might have been made.
- I don't put ketchup with any food
because I feel like ketchup overpowers
the taste of the foods.
- I don't even put ketchup on my fries.
- I like ketchup.
- Here we go.
Ah, that sounded sensual.
- I only taste ketchup.
This is why I don't like ketchup.
- It does taste a bit like
sriracha, like no joke.
(quiet laughing)
- Oh God.
Would I do it again?
(beep) no.
- Almonds and honey; here we go.
- The fuck am I doing today?
This is another day at Buzzfeed.
- This is something I
can get on board with
'cause I love me some sweets
and I love me some nuts.
- If there's a milk, I feel like
it's gonna taste like cereal.
- This seems really healthy for you.
- Is that why I don't like it?
- Also the good thing about
this, it's like all natural.
- The more I eat it, the
more I'm getting used to it.
- I feel like that's gonna be my favorite.
- Orange juice and cheese?
Also, I'm lactose intolerant!
- This is the worst one so far.
- Do you want me to like dip this
cheese in this orange juice?
Is that what you want me to do?
- You gotta bite into it
and then have some OJ.
Bite into it and OJ.
- Is that what you want me to do?
- Surprisingly, I can
barely taste anything.
- Cheddar cheese is very prominent
so it kinda overpowers the
OJ, but I kinda like it.
- There's something really
wrong with this image.
Kids, look away.
Yep, disgusting.
- Okay, something's
wrong with my taste buds.
I can't taste anything.
- Just leave it separate, they're good
on their own, don't combine them.
- Mediterranean mint ice cream
and some good old wasabi.
- Are you serious?
Alex!
Look at this ice cream.
It's melted.
- This is gonna be horrendous.
- This is a lot of wasabi.
- All right. Drink?
- Did I mention I'm lactose intolerant?
Pretty much this whole entire video
could just be like ways to
make Kevin shit himself.
- Cheers.
- Yes. Cheers.
- No oh oh.
No, no, no, no, no.
No.
- Oh no.
Aw.
- Eh.
This is not pleasant.
- That is probably one of the worst
things I've ever put in my mouth.
And I've put some pretty
bad things in my mouth.
- Don't try this at home.
- I learned that you should
leave the food as it is.
I mean there's a reason why
they're not together, right?
- I like trying new things,
maybe not these kinds of foods.
- If they're the same color,
they shouldn't be mixed together.
- That's how you make the
best of a bad situation.
- Deuce.
(instrumental music)
(whooshing)
(creaking)